welcome everybody back from Princeton
talking about optimization three
approaches to optimization
yes also a OPN associated fire okay okay
so let me jump right right into this so
this is the problem that I'm interested
in solving in this problem in this talk
I have a multivariate polynomial P and a
basic semi algebraic set defined by a
finite number of polynomial inequalities
and I want to decide is P non-negative
when evaluated on a point from this set
or in some other problems maybe some
coefficients of peer decision variables
and I want to find these coefficients in
such a way that the resulting polynomial
becomes non-negative on this set
okay so throughout the talk this is this
is my problem and let me quickly tell
you why you would want to do this and at
a high level I want to cover some
applications in these three areas so
probably the most obvious application of
this is to solve or give a lower give
very good lower bounds for polynomial
optimization problems so let's say I
want to minimize P on this set well if I
can prove that P minus the constant
gamma is non-negative on this set well
that gamma is a lower bound on my poem
optimization problem and if I find the
highest search gamma I have found the
optimal value of my problem okay
another problem which is essentially
equivalent is to prove in feasibility of
a system of polynomial inequalities and
there are many non trivial problems that
can be formulated as such so here I have
a famous one in geometry and I'm sure
many of you have seen this I'll give you
a central sphere of radius 1 and I asked
you how many other spheres can you put
around it so should all the white
spheres simultaneously touch the black
one but they do not overlap with each
other I wasn't coefficients are both
real so it is easy to give a
construction to say that you can do 12
but it's quite non-trivial to show that
you cannot do 13 and in fact this was
famously open for a couple centuries
when you're almost trivially you can
write down a set of inequalities that if
you could show they were infeasible
you would solve this problem so what are
my variables here there
of the white spheres the first set of
equations tell me that the radius is 2
so that ensures that they all touch the
black sphere and the other ones tell me
that the distance between the centre of
any two white spheres is at least 2 so
that ensures that these white spheres do
not overlap so how would you show the
system is infeasible using the problem
on the top well if I have a system of
inequalities G 1 2 G hundred that I want
to show is infeasible that's the same as
showing okay if G 1 2 G 99 are satisfied
then G 100 is not right so then you have
to show you know G 100 is negative
whenever the other guys are positive so
it's exactly a problem of this type we
quickly give you a problem in statistics
called shape constrained regression so
suppose I want to fit a polynomial
function to a bunch of data points in RN
but I want to ensure that my polynomial
has some shape constraints so for
instance is convex or is monotone with
respect to certain directions so let me
give you a concrete example if my
polynomial is supposed to predict the
price of a car as a function of a number
of features of the car then if you have
two cars that are exactly the same
except one is older than the other then
it better be that I predict the cheaper
price for this car than for that car if
I want to impose such a property on my
regressor that's the non-negativity
condition on the partial derivative of
my polynomial so again it's a problem of
this thing now in controls there's many
many applications but one of the most
well-known ones is to design stabilizing
controllers so suppose you have a
differential equation X dot equals f of
X F is a map from RN to RN each entry is
a polynomial and you want to design a
controller that stabilizes this around
an equilibrium point so think this is an
equilibrium point that's the point where
F is 0 so in this cartoon it could be
where the robot is exactly balanced in
state space and somebody can push the
robot and your task is to design a
controller so that pushes you away from
the equilibrium that draws the
trajectories back to the origin and
ideally you want the size of this region
of Attraction to be as large as possible
ok how would you do this so the Apple of
steering tells you that if you find a
function V from RN to
which is positive and on the beta sub
levels the V the derivative of the
function is negative or the inner
product of the gradient would f is
negative then you have a proof that the
beta sublevel set is contained inside
the region of Attraction okay so if
you've seen this this is this is well
known but the point is that now if I if
I parameterize V as a polynomial
function the task of finding the
coefficients subject to these three
constraints or these two constraints is
again the problem of optimizing over non
negative polymers okay so hopefully I
convince you that this problem is
interesting now how would you actually
do this and as many of you know there
are theorems in algebraic geometry they
typically typically come under the name
of positive students that allow you to
to actually do exactly this so this
means a theorem about positivity so one
of the most fundamental wonder one of
the earliest ones is due to our team and
it does the global case so if you have
no constraints and if you want to prove
eponymous globally positive or
non-negative then it says that you can
always find a certificate of the
following form you can always find
another polynomial Q which is the sum of
squares
there's sum of squares of other
polynomials just just P times Q is a sum
of squares ok if you have such a
certificate in P times Q is non-negative
that implies that P itself must be
non-negative
now if you have constraints people later
develop their there are other famous
result so I have three of them here due
to stengel shmoop again and put in R
which says which we state the following
if a polymer is positive on a basic semi
algebraic set there's always a certain
proof of this algebraic proof of this
based on sums of scores again so let's
look at Putin ours for example is the
simplest one to describe says if P is
positive on s then you can always find
sum of squares polynomials Sigma 0 Sigma
I such that this algebraic identity
holds so why is this interesting because
you know if I have such a decomposition
then if I evaluate P at a point in my
set gia in my set s then these terms are
non-negative sums of squares are
non-negative and I can conclude that P
is non-negative ok
but what's amazing is that the converse
is true you know under my assumptions if
P is not negative on an S then there is
such a decomposition now why are we
interested in these results it's because
we again I assume most of you know this
we can find such sum of squares
polynomials automatically by solving
semi definite programs and if you've
seen things like the luster and the
parallel hierarchy this is exactly what
they do so they they set up an SDP which
which tries to find you know such sum of
squares polynomials so I'm not going to
review the details but take this as the
fact if you haven't seen it optimizing
over the set of a source polynomial is a
fixed degree can be done by solving an
SDP of polynomial size the end of my
quick review the motivation for this
talk is partly practical and partly
theoretical the practical part is that
is SDP is rare now we all know are
expensive to solve and as scalability is
a real challenge in practice so for
instance if you're interested in these
control problems and if your
differential equation has 20 state
variables you end up with an SDP
typically which has over a million
decision variables even for a quadratic
Lyapunov function okay and this is far
beyond what we can actually solve so
most problem or most applications in
controls I use these techniques usually
having a five to ten variables and
mostly so the agenda for today's talk is
the following my goal is to see if you
can we avoid semi definite programming
in the problem of optimizing over non
negative polynomials I'll give you three
results so the first is some recent
effort we have to to derive LPNs OCP
based alternatives to sum of squares
this is what we call D sauce and st
sauce techniques program so it's a
cheaper class of convex optimization
problems it's much closer to LP than to
STP terms of complexity all right and
the second one is the second one is the
more recent result is I give what what
as far as I know is the first
optimization free positive silencer so
what that means is that I give you a
proof of positivity of the polynomial on
the basic semi algebraic set
that does not require any type of LP or
STP to find the certificates it turns
out that the only will require that you
multiply certain fixed polynomials
together and check if the product has
non-negative coefficients so we'll get
to that and then if there's time I want
to add with the end quickly with the
metal theorem that sets aside sort of a
minimal set of requirements to
approximate you know homogeneous
non-negative polynomials and it says
okay if you could do this then you could
produce a hierarchy for polynomial
optimization okay and that sort of
unifies what we do in the second part we
also have to say so the first part is
joint work with an imaging dar who's not
my colleague at Princeton number two and
three is a recent paper with Georgina
Hall is my student she's on the market
she's away at Stanford today but she'll
be giving a talk here on Thursday any
questions so far
okay so let's get right to it so what is
how can we find cheaper ways of
optimizing over non negative polynomials
so I did geometric level the idea is
very simple I spent 20 minutes so so
what I have on the outside is a set of
positive or non-negative polynomial so
think of this as a picture in
coefficient space and optimizing over
this black set is intractable what we do
instead is we optimize over sums of
squares and this MSTP so the question is
you know can I go inside and find
something which is more tractable so the
first one I want to make is that not any
subset of SOS is necessarily more
tractable so so for instance is it's
probably hard to optimize over the set
of polynomials there are some the fourth
powers of other polynomials or there are
some of squares of a constant number of
partners this is some of five squares or
three squares so there are sets within
here that are even harder to optimize
over then SOS but there are other ones
that are easier and this this is the
notion of de saucé and SS as polynomials
so as a reminder polynomials a sum of
squares if and only if you can write it
in this form so let's say P has degree 2
D Z of X is a vector of all possible
monomials you can have up to degree D
andcue is a symmetric matrix that you
have to find which is positive
semi-definite and that's where the STP
comes from okay so the idea is very
simple what is the D sauce polynomial
what is the polynomial which is exactly
the same representation except I don't
ask you to be PST I ask you to be
diagonally dominant so what that means
is that each diagonal entry of the
matrix is larger than the sum of the
other entries in absolute value in that
row
okay so well-known fact that diagonally
dominant matrices are PST so this gives
you a subset of their source polynomials
why do I like this because you know in
fact optimizing over these polynomials
is a clearly a linear program because
these are linear inequalities in the
entries of Q ok there is an intermediate
one that we call st sauce polynomials so
what is an ST sauce for number is a
polynomial P which again has the same
representation except Q's has to be
scaled diagonally dominant or STD so
what is such a matrix so Q is STD so it
may not be diagonally dominant but there
is a mate if there is a matrix D D is
diagonal and he has positive diagonals
associate DQ D is diagonally dominant so
essentially these matrices are diagonal
dominant after rescaling of rows and
columns so it turns out that you can
optimize over these matrices with second
order cone programs so I can tell you
how offline if you're interested but
sort of this now gives you an
intermediate set because clearly if
you're diagonally dominant you can take
this DT identity so the orange is a
subset of the blue thank you okay so
let's actually see how this doesn't an
actual example so here I have a
parametric family of bivariate cortex of
two parameters a and B and I'm plotting
the set of values of a and B for which
the problem is a sum of squares I notice
that that does a perfect job of getting
all non-negative polynomials the
polytope insides the de saucé
polynomials and the white is the second
order comm program one is the STS one
okay so you can start from this and
there are many ways of improving this
you know this technique let me quickly
mention a couple of obvious ones so for
instance you can do this standard
business of producing hierarchy is you
know motivated by what was done in there
so it's literature so you can define a
polynomial to be rd sauce if P is not
the sauce but P after multiplication by
some of X I squared to the rsd sauce so
this is something you can still import
with a linear program and it's still a
sufficient condition for P to be
non-negative and if you do this and you
raise our from one two and so on you get
this increasing family of inner
approximations for instance R equal to
one is the white part I mean this is the
SOC P version on the same example in
fact you can show you that if your
polynomial is even meaning that all the
variables are only R raised to even
powers then this hierarchy is complete
meaning that you know even if you have a
positive polynomial eventually we'll be
artists us for some R ok and this is not
a restrictive family in fact if you have
any problem in NP you can reduce it to
the task of checking if an even degree
four polynomial is non-negative ok so
it's already an interesting class the
second technique which is much more
useful in practice because it's cheaper
than the than the previous heart is the
following so let me motivate it by by an
example to suppose I have this
polynomial here now this polynomial is a
sum of squares here is a proof I found
the matrix which is positive
semi-definite so take my word for it but
it's not the sauce so clearly this
matrix is not diagonally dominant and it
just so happens that there is no other
matrix which is diagonally dominant and
satisfies this equation but here's the
observation so if if instead of the
standard monomial basis Z somehow I had
a better basis C tilde so some of this
basis then in this basis I could find
such a such a matrix in fact I can find
the diagonal one so the idea is can I
start with the standard monomial basis
and iteratively find better basis for
which diagonal dominance does better ok
so here is a way to do this
and this idea is is applicable to in
fact to any SDP but just for
concreteness I I give it to you for a
concrete problem so suppose you want to
minimize a multivariate polynomial P
globally yes here's how you do it so you
try to prove that gamma is a global
lower bound by showing that P minus
gamma is equal to Z transpose Q Z and Q
is a diagonally dominant matrix okay so
you go and solve this LP it returns a
value maybe gamma star is equal to 10
then you take the optimal ground matrix
Q and you do actual S key factorization
on it you transpose U and now you update
your basis from Z of X to u times Z of X
that's a new basis and then you resolve
so let's see what happens if I resolve
now in this new problem if I set Q to be
identity then u transpose U is a
previous optimal solution so I recover
at least the previous bound 10 but you
know now Q has more freedom it can be
diagonal dominance I can do possibly
better and this actually does quite
duvall so here is a parametric family
again so this is my D source
approximation and suppose I'm interested
in optimizing in that direction here is
just one iteration of this idea you can
see how much it improves it and this is
the specific version of the same thing
ok so now now to show you some examples
of you know how much faster is this then
sstp for for for a range of problems so
I'm going to revisit this stabilization
problem in in control and as my first
problem I want to stabilize an inverted
pendulum with n links so N equals 1 is
just the task of stabilizing this N
equals 2 it's actually something that my
collaborator implemented in the lab at
MIT where so on imagine Baron trusted
Drake if you can see
no it has to be over
so this is actually a controller
designed by sum of squares programs that
does this perfectly now the largest STP
we could solve is n equal to 6 so here
your system will have 12 states and STP
is taking you know close to 7 hours if
you subdue me or half an hour if you use
mosaic the LPNs or CP taking the order
of just 10 seconds ok of course what you
lose is something is the size of the
region of Attraction will be smaller
what we can actually show the volume of
the region of Attraction there so CP
case is 70% of the STP which is sorry no
because we didn't have it but so here's
another one which they did not implement
but is in simulation is a realistic
model of a robot called the Atlas and
this is a problem where the control
system has 30 states is 14 control
inputs and we're doing the soc p version
here so there is a Lyapunov function in
the background that you're automatically
finding and you're proving that is
non-negative around the origin
using this SD saw certificates ok
so that's that was the first thing now I
want to tell you a bit about its
positive sentences that do not use
optimization so here it's here the
theorem is very simply described so
remember what I'm interested is proving
that a certain polynomial is positive on
a basic semi algebraic set there's a
theorem this is true if and only if this
giant polynomial here has non-negative
coefficients where there is a parameter
or or is an integer which appears here
and appears in these coefficients here
so what is f so I'm not writing what F
is but F is a homogeneous polynomial in
n plus M plus 3 variables so n is the
original number of variables M is the
number of constraints and its degrees
for D if the largest degree I had
everywhere here was to D so essentially
I'm lifting the problem into you know
slightly higher dimension I double the
degree but this is something I can
explicitly write down from these things
and everything else is completely fixed
right so V and W are new variables so if
instead of plugging in X 1 you plug in
you know V 1 minus W 1 that's what this
notation means right and then everything
else is completely fixed and you form
this polynomial you multiply it by the
sky for less than or equal to 1 if he
has non-negative coefficients you're
done you have a proof of positivity if
it's not you go up and this procedure is
guaranteed to terminate if P is actually
positive no just like you don't know
when in the SOS case so this very
similar situation there is a bound
actually but depends on the minimum of P
on the set which if he knew then you
didn't need to solve this is exactly
like the put in our case actually
yes is it what was in the background
it's police there okay so let me give
you a slide on you know where does this
come from idea of the proof so so first
there is a this this step I'm skipping
there is a reduction in the proof that
changes the problem of proving P is
non-negative on this set to the problem
of proving that a homogeneous polynomial
is positive definite so you give me P
and G I give you a homogeneous
polynomial which is positive definite if
and only if P was positive and that's
not hard to do okay and then the task is
to just do that all right so that's
essentially how you get rid of the
constraints now now the problem is okay
so then we use like Greg said we use
this result Apulia which amazingly
enough is this is one page to prove so
the and our proof is also elementary so
from start to finish this positive
sentences is purely algebraic and very
simple to prove so it says the following
if f is an even polynomial so if all
variables are raised to even powers then
there is an R such that this product has
non-negative coefficients now what is
the problem my F does not there's no
reason for it to be even because you
know I did not assume that P and G is
are even so here's why we introduce
these new variables so you go from F of
Z to F of V squared minus W squared so
any vector in RN can be written as a
difference of two non-negative vectors
if you do this operation then you're
even unfortunately what you lose is you
lose positive definiteness so even F if
F was positive definite now this is a
new form but it's not positive definite
so if W is equal to V of 0 alright so we
have to do something about this so this
is why the orange term is added so you
add something to it to make it positive
definite and then the first and the
third part are positive definite you
apply poly as result is some appropriate
power and you get non-negative
coefficients what is the problem is I
know I cannot just randomly add
something positive you know what if I my
Parliament was negative and now I made
it positive right so you have to
subtract something to avoid that from
happening and that's what the second
term is doing right so essentially if
you have all the three terms then you
have the following property if
F was positive then the sum of the three
terms is still positive but if F was
negative
at some point on the unit sphere then
the sum of the three terms is still
negative at some point on the atmosphere
so that's that's what's happening here
and you know we haven't applied this to
anything yet but you know potentially it
could have some applications because you
know if you know now all these problems
in sphere packing and now you know if
you have a good way of you know
intelligence this multiplying
polynomials in high number of variables
and then all you need to do is to check
if the coefficients are non-negative
okay it's potentially can be done so
just a quick comment as a corollary this
also gives you new converging
hierarchies for polymer optimization
based on LPNs OCP based on this D saw
stuff that I was talking about so the
only thing that you need to change is
that you know here I had some of the
variables squared to the are you can
change that to a new polynomial Q which
is now a decision variable and you ask
it to be D sauce and you ask the product
to be D sauce okay or SD sauce so this
will trivially do better how much that
man so I'm good I'm really gonna have
two more slides okay so why because you
see the polynomial that I have here is
even and my previous theorem said that
at some point if you multiply this by
some of the variable squares it will
have non-negative coefficients now if an
even polynomial has non-negative
coefficients what can you say about this
gram matrix well you can always take his
grand matrix to actually be diagonal all
right because you have all the monomials
coefficients are non-negative so even if
you take it diagonal gram matrix this
will converge so of course it will
converge if you make it to be diagonally
dominant or scale Diadema dominant but
the point is that this could converge
faster to the actual order okay and this
sort of brings me to the last two slides
on my talk which is this metric theorem
which actually the previous stuff was
based on and he tells you that you know
if you could design a set of cones with
the following four properties then you
would you could produce a hierarchy of
converging lower bounds for polymer
optimization okay so notice that there
is no constraints here so
the only task is to is to be able to
inner approximate the set of
non-negative or non-negative homogeneous
polynomials in any variables are too
greedy if you could do this then you can
apply this machinery to to produce a
hierarchy so we're the statements so if
you have a set of cones or a set of
homogeneous polynomials in n variables
agree to the index by r which have the
following property so all of them are
subsets of non negative polynomials and
there is sort of a positive definite
element so this is almost trivial so you
can always pretty much take this to be
some of X I squared to the D so there's
a central element which is positive
definite in the first one the second one
is actually the hardest one to satisfy
that's a key one which says if you have
any point in the interior of this set
there will be some level of the
hierarchy which will contain it that's
what the second one says it's like the
third one says that this the sets are
nested and the fourth one is again
trivial it says that you know if you
take care if you take a positive number
which is in the set and you move towards
the central element is still in the set
so in particularly if your sets are
convex for is satisfied immediately okay
so if you have these things then you
here's how you get a converging
hierarchy for polynomial time ization
again there's this polynomial F which
comes from the reduction again the
details do not matter but but this would
be your hierarchy so at each step you
check whether a certain polynomial is in
a certain cone so previously a my this
membership was just checking
coefficients being non-negative but this
could be you know an LP could be an SDP
it could be anything you want right so
the complexity of your hierarchy depends
on the complexity of checking this
membership in particular here's an
example of a set of cones that satisfy
this property we call it the art in
cones so these are the set of
polynomials in any variables agree to D
for which there exists the sum of
squares polynomial Q such a P times Q is
SOS and Q as degree to R you can easily
show that this satisfies all four
properties so the hardest one is number
two but that's exactly our tins theorem
and then what this gives you is that you
know already our teens result is enough
to produce a hierarchy of lower bounds
converging lower bounds copolymer
optimization
okay so that's it the main messages of
this talk were that you know there are
many different ways of inner
approximating the set of non-negative
polynomials
now prominently we do this with STPs but
they're ways of doing it with LPS or CP
or simply by polymer multiplication and
any of them would lead to a converging
hierarchy of lower bounds for polymer
optimization that's a good question
something both me and my student are
working on we don't have a proof of
convergence but I can tell you some
stuff about it so first of all we have
some variants of this which use column
generation and they do converge but if
you if you were if you if you're
interested in this particular algorithm
I know for a fact that this doesn't
always converge so what can happen so we
can prove that you always go to the
boundary of the SDP
but you can go somewhere other than the
optimal solution now you need to do
something you need to make sure that
each iterate is positive it stays
positive definite so instead of solving
these LPS to optimality if you step back
a little bit then there's a chance of
convergence so that's what we were
working on but I don't know well at
least you need to do that
yes hi he says he some squares a
combination of both linear programming
in terms of spectral techniques
I guess the examples of shorts that the
trying to push the linear programming
are the examples why you think of sum of
squares as LP and so you can solve any
their techniques I'm sure you know that
multiplicative weight updates they solve
any SDP with just stop again back to
computation
with your hierarchies I don't understand
the question can you rephrase so I don't
know why you think of an SDP as lp+ yes
see one thing if there is a smart
algorithm that use lp+ eigenvector
computation somewhere that's a good
question
I I don't know we don't do that actually
here I mean you can sort of thinking
think of cholesky is yeah I mean it's
terms of complex is equivalent when I
get my little composition but but no I
don't know but you can also do the full
STP chess with topic and vector
computation
any other questions so as I understood
you have a heuristics but you don't know
if they ever conversely you know like it
are large enough then these are not here
Asics these are theorems right so yeah
this the the proof of this is exactly
the same that the most you can say for
SOS right so if you have a hierarchy
sorry so each each each fixed level of
these hierarchies is a linear program of
polynomial size just like I don't
understand what you're saying so okay so
that's what I'm saying so there's
there's actually you cannot disprove
ibly you cannot bound are neither in my
hierarchy nor in the SOS hierarchy as a
function of number of variables and
degree of the problem only so this
depends on the coefficients in a in a
difficult way it depends on the minimum
of the polynomial in the basics of an
algebraic set possibly you can say
something there I don't know if this is
known now there's an exception to this
if you use string goes positive silence
our our tintype results where you allow
a free multiplier then you can bound the
level only as a function of N and D the
bounds are polynomial in D but the best
bounds are knowing n or multiple towers
of exponential like five towers of
exponential
[Applause]